la casa de estos policías talibanes
comienza en medio de la noche persiguen
a los drogadictos que deambulan por la
ciudad se dice que el país tiene 4
millones de ellos es decir casi el 10
por ciento de la población
los rescatamos de las drogas para
devolverlos al buen camino para darles
una buena vida en sociedad porque esa es
nuestra responsabilidad como nuevo
gobierno esta noche frente a nuestra
cámara no encuentra ninguna
por la gracia de alá hemos limpiado esta
zona de drogadictos y eso es porque
hemos detenido a todos los vendedores de
droga
estuviste con nosotros durante esta
patrulla viste algún drogadicto no hay
más
desde su llegada al poder los talibanes
afirman haber erradicado prácticamente
la inseguridad en las ciudades sin
embargo a unos cientos de metros otra
patrulla está llevando a cabo una dura
operación para escuchar a los
drogadictos
las únicas imágenes de esta intervención
serán firmadas con un smartphone con un
civil presente en el lugar de los hechos
métodos comunes de expulsión que no
impiden que vuelvan a la mañana
siguiente
este terreno baldío en el oeste de kabul
es uno de los cuarteles generales de los
narcotraficantes
según estos drogadictos la violencia
contra ellos ha aumentado desde la
llegada a los talibanes
los talibanes hacen incursiones todo el
tiempo
vienen con sus palos a golpearnos a sus
carnes pero siempre fuimos pero a veces
no dudan en disparar los con sus
kalashnikov de la bala estos hombres
viven en condiciones inhumanas en medio
de las aguas residuales de kabul cada
mes mueren drogadictos en este lugar y
son enterrados aquí en el barro cuando
encontramos cadáveres mis caras están
cubiertas de abejas el último muerto que
encontramos de cubrir la cara con el
trapo pero aún así las abejas seguían
entrando así que lo enterramos
rápidamente la adicción a la heroína no
es un fenómeno nuevo en afganistán
ninguno de los gobiernos anteriores ha
logrado detenerla
cómo
entre 1996 y 2001 cuando su anterior
régimen estaba en el poder los
fundamentalistas casi habían eliminado
la producción de opio hasta la fecha
representa el 85% de la producción
mundial hoy los talibanes son más
ambiguos el código de conducta emitido
por el ministerio para la promoción de
la virtud y represión del vicio es
inequívoco
se prohíbe el consumo de cannabis opio y
drogas
pero los talibanes hacen saber que solo
dejarán de producir opio bajo ciertas
condiciones
el año pasado nuestros dirigentes dieron
la orden de que los talibanes no pueden
interferir en las actividades agrícolas
relacionadas con la amapola
por otro lado si la comunidad
internacional no reconoce oficialmente
pediremos la plantación de esta
sustancia como ocurrió durante nuestro
gobierno antes de 2001
cuando no llegan a ser palizas las
redadas realizadas por los talibanes
conducen al encarcelamiento o más
raramente a la desintoxicación forzosa
como en este hospital especializado
donde los combos son escasos puede
contarme más sobre su aviación de 8 años
consumiendo heroína
al principio durante dos años sólo
consumía opio luego seguido en la
heroína
ahora que está ingresando en este
hospital cómo se siente
es mejor desde que estoy aquí
me siento mejor y la abstinencia es
menos difícil de soportar
tras la reciente toma de posición de los
talibanes washington congeló la reserva
del banco central afgano casi 10 mil
millones de dólares desde que se bloqueó
la ayuda al desarrollo el centro está
asfixiado financieramente
si no recibimos ningún apoyo de la
comunidad internacional
todo se detendrá
esto ya es casi un hecho
ya que nuestras actividades se han
reducido en un 70%
si el dinero no llega entonces
automáticamente estos centros tendrán
que cerrar
según la onu el 97% de los afganos
podría caer por debajo del umbral de la
pobreza en los próximos meses ante el
colapso del país es poco probable que
los nuevos líderes erradiquen el consumo
de drogas en afganistán a corto plazo